[Music]
in warn the kids news on the kids
submitted by don't listen to geo no
don't listen do you
oh I fixed it officials are wearing the
public about another suicide game making
its way through social media
oh god oh wait why me not listening kind
of sensitive to it oh yeah thank you did
you find in complain so much
that's me alright you guys remember what
we talked about that blue whale yeah I
remember that
they're like suicide game that was going
around but it was popular in Russia or
so yeah they were like over a dozen
suicide what's the game so basically
they condition the kids as they're
playing this game to commit to a certain
things like psychologically disturbing
thing right and then at the end the goal
is to get the kid to kill themself it's
pretty [ __ ] twisted yeah yeah it's
really twisted like the steps get you
condition yourself to want to kill
yourself yeah holy [ __ ] and the first
step is just like it's like you're
you're saying yes I would like wanna go
eat a hamburger or something simple and
it just keeps going and going and going
the middle step was I stand in the
middle of railroad tracks but then jump
off right when the train gets close
enough
that's like inches inches you closer to
being able to do it yeah yeah so now
there's this new one that apparently has
already claimed one life a 12 year old
girl in Argentina she killed herself and
filmed it and this new one they're
calling Momo like Momo challenge and
they're they have this challenge with
this image here oh my god
scary hey that looks like a Japanese
ghost alright but then it's got cleavage
so I'm kind of conflicted
this is yeah
that's the first thing I saw you guys
freaking out about oh [ __ ] nice titties
good titties that is the work of a
Japanese doll artist named Midori
Hayashi
yeah cuz it looks like a Japanese ghost
it's we have a ghost like that like a
[ __ ] bird creature that thing those
are kind of scary though Japanese at all
that's very western yeah like has very
western features it's it's modernized oh
yeah yeah I thought it was like some Tim
Burton's yeah it does looks like oh yeah
yeah but yet so this this game here
they're playing on what's up they're
getting we don't know who's behind it
you could tell us Japanese by the
cleavage like they just had to sexualize
yeah I know they press it together dude
yeah they're like it's got to have
luscious titties timber nuns like
titties like that yeah no he doesn't
you like the tiny little titties yeah
yeah no full image the feet
they're like chicken feet oh damn dim
sum that's what it look like in the
morning cuz [ __ ] tight eyes doesn't
ever let me sleep in it that's your
happy meth head Vegas girl yeah how does
that play into the game at 7:00 a.m.
that's just the image that's attached to
the show okay but that the Japanese
artist doesn't have anything to do with
it oh it's like like the little icon
like because you said they send it to
you via whatsapp so that little icon
sends it to you what if the Japanese
artist finds out that eating it that
he's tied to this game and he's like oh
oh that's so bad I don't want my
branding to be tied like that well
that's probably happening because it's
like I just want to make a scary
seeing's
you know like he doesn't really want
people to [ __ ] do some murderous [ __ ]
it's true yeah but they're they're
tracing the numbers
and this has been going on in like
different countries so even in the u.s.
people are playing this game what's the
game well it's pretty much the same
thing as a blue whale challenge like
their conditioning people someone just
steps that leads that lead up to it like
waking up in odd hours being
sleep-deprived anem and then yeah
they're just [ __ ] psychologically
getting them into ready to [ __ ] kill
themselves yeah and then like they're
just they're just flooding these
teenagers minds are just graphic violent
images so they keep texting on like
super violent things and yeah just
pretty much wanting them to get into
this mind state of wanting to kill
himself at the end so they're reporting
that countries around the world which
would be Argentina Mexico the US France
Germany but it's mainly popular in the
Latin American countries and so they
they don't know who's doing this but
they're targeting teenagers that's crazy
like no one comes out and says I made it
you know like they just some psycho [ __ ]
and maybe his friend programming friends
is [ __ ] build it and release it out
of interesting though because it all
means that that kind of brings up that
topic about how a lot of people are
saying like oh well these violent images
from videos and games that won't mold
your child's thoughts like it's just
about parenting but this kind of shows
the exact opposite yeah that but I said
like a succession of certain images
causes people suicidal thoughts so maybe
oh we're kind of like flips flip that
over or it could only only work on kids
that are already susceptible to this
come on maybe a sound kid might look at
these images and go this shit's [ __ ]
forced but that's the point though
there's a reason why kids shouldn't
watch certain things but you don't know
that well this is a psychologically
persuasive journey we're like we're
gonna see the show and that flips called
the push it's really interesting it's
really you saw oh wait I saw the movie
oh no exact what word like they put
random people in scenarios and somehow
the
we don't watch I don't want you so yeah
Mandy was so interesting the a mentalist
guy he designed a scenario where a guy
would go through like a regular person
or woman would go through a series of
events that it ends with them like at
the end of the night feeling seeing
someone off of a building to kill them
to protect themselves
yeah like and it's and it's crazy like
it and the person's like they really try
to murder this person and this person is
not trying to kill them or anything yeah
like it's insane but most people try to
save their ass no most people push the
guy yeah yeah they kill them to save
their own skin it was [ __ ] interesting
you should watch it it's really good but
but basically it's like instead of it
being like well it's video games or it's
images or whatever it's really just
about the the whole journey like yeah
it's the psychological conditioning of
how do you get people like if you bring
them through the step-by-step you could
get somebody to kill I mean let's talk
about our military right like humans are
not born to kill naturally right that's
something that's scary to do even
violence is something scary to do it has
to be taught over time especially to
kill somebody you never met before that
you basically you know like has nothing
against there's no anger behind it so
you have to condition someone to be okay
with murdering other people that you
have no attachment or you have no no no
reason to kill for any other reason they
got this guy on the show too so they had
like someone who was supposed to be
speaking that night at like a charity
function they had him like die of a
heart attack in front of the guy and and
so then they hide him in a box
and then the guy pretended to be the
speaker guy and give the speech the
speaker I was gonna give because they
peer pressured him and do all of it I
would have been like [ __ ] no and I said
I would have started swinging at people
you think you wanted really I want to
put me on the [ __ ] show but they slow
blended enough where they really didn't
he really didn't know better he really
thought he was doing the right thing by
doing
and then he was in over his head and he
just kept on doing the wrong thing over
and over again so we work well into the
traffic oh they asked him they had the
body like they were dragging it down
some stairs and they asked him to kick
it to make it look like he had fallen
down the stairs and he didn't do that
but they cut to a bunch of other people
who have been put through the same
scenario who did like it's [ __ ] like
looks like they went from watching guys
I have a heart attack to abusing his
corpse to pushing someone a lot of
people know they're on this like show
right there you don't know they don't
know that I got double-blind study where
you think you're doing your rating
televisions but actually questioning
about your sex life didn't even know
about it
yeah it's it's it's like they have him
there and they didn't know he's being
filmed or anything and it was a but it
was having a bunch away you're so
unethical yeah but it's a great
experiment that's a social experiment
all these other [ __ ] pranksters doing
shows that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] that is a
real social experiment it sauce can you
push someone to the limit but I want to
know how much priming and prepping they
did because that's very biased like they
could even you know you know they're
psychologists for shows right they could
find someone that's more likely to be
convinced by other people it doesn't
make for good TV if you have a strong
will person going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you I'm calling the cops
that's how bad because you don't just
find strong warm people everywhere like
it like it really seems like a fair
study that's true because most people
are like there's like more people than
not are willing to go with the flow
that's true
damn that's why to say so then do you
say all this - I guess counter whatever
David just said yeah I don't think it's
I don't think video game violent video
games creates whatever the [ __ ] I think
all that [ __ ] is so hype like it's
almost always environmental it's almost
always like the way the kids being
treated at school it's almost always
like some neglectful parent has a gun in
the house like I don't think it's ever
just like imagery or like they saw
Jurassic Park so now they think they can
[ __ ] kill people or whatever yeah
well I'm not saying I'm not saying watch
that I believe that more than anything
else but like I'm
like it adds to it that it centrally
overload you know I mean so like if they
have like X amount of violent movies of
day right there watching my [ __ ] 10
violent shits they're playing [ __ ]
violent games all day maybe it does say
something to that then because of this I
believe that more but now this kind of
makes me think the other way a little
bit you know because the brain doesn't
know the difference between reality and
fantasy like if there's a murder
happening in on screen it doesn't know
the difference between that and watching
someone get killed in real life like it
can't differentiate between the two
images yeah so maybe because that makes
me think like if I have a kid decide
well maybe I should just be I care a
little more than you know not just let
them watch everything for sure you know
because before I was going the other way
I'm lying and go do whatever now I'm
like maybe I should control a little bit
Tycho watched 300 on a second day on
earth he didn't really watch it and
what's going on no a bunch of bouncing
white tiger was doing this Tiger was
doing this yeah so just last month it
they reported that there was this 22
year old guy from Moscow who might have
been the mastermind behind blue well
damn so I mean where do people even get
it don't tell me cuz then that's where
everyone's gonna find where to get it
get what the game the info oh I already
said it all I wasn't listening it's on
what's that like that really yeah people
are well I don't use that you might need
a secret number or something yeah there
are all these different numbers who that
they have traced back to Japan and Latin
American country Wow cuz those two are
so similar yeah you know yeah I think as
a kid you want to play with fire so I
would see myself playing with this when
I was like 13 yet seeing how like strong
you are
yeah I'm like it's not gonna get me to
kill Matthew that's why a lot of Russian
kids I'm doing it cuz we're not as
strong as they think it was they're too
strong it's like Bloody Mary dude yep I
wanted to test my [ __ ] man I couldn't
sleep for [ __ ] like three years oh
doing Bloody Mary
so cuz I was convinced I felt like this
I did it and my friends like come on man
it doesn't work and then we all did it
and then I was like [ __ ] what if I
unlocked a beast like what if I unlocked
it but she's just come in later and I
was [ __ ] layer yes she wasn't murderer
ever dude and then later and she's
coming he was like we were having a
sleepover in shade he's like he's like
he was helping me like Joe I'll do with
you I care it's not gonna happen anymore
cuz I kept telling him how scared I was
we [ __ ] did that [ __ ] and I was like
oh [ __ ] I just caught her again she just
didn't come that's so funny like I just
pictured he's thinking like Bloody Mary
has a hot pocket in the microwave but
she forgot like that [ __ ] Bloody Mary
buddy man hold on yeah what's up with
the argument for buddy Mary's flawed
because you have to it's fortunate was
at the same time and be alone oh I
didn't know that I thought you just I
thought you were just supposed to go
into the mirror and say it ten times or
whatever I thought you have to do it and
okay everyone has different rules
[Music]
[Music]